[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israel
heute ist eine richtig leckere
marokkanischen eintopf und zwar einen
sieger im einsatz der ist vegetarisch
und dem rat wird gar nicht auffallen das
war kein fleisch mit dabei ist denn ich
hab erst wieder tolle gemüsesorten die
machen das ganze natürlich fair
variationsreich und das besondere daran
sie natürlich gewürze
das ist natürlich ein paar exotische
gewürze wieder mit dabei wie zb
koriander samen und kurkuma die
natürlich auch sehr gesund sind
ich hab's ja immer in meinem fahrrad
fahren und ich denke wenn ihr euch hier
einmal zulegt dann könnte immer richtig
schönes exotisches zaubern
ich finde ich einfach nochmal die flut
hatten ich brauche zwei esslöffel
olivenöl knoblauch nämlich eine label
ein stück ingwer eine 5 kartoffel und
bei kartoffeln gerne jeweils 500 gramm
eine zucchini ein fenster eine rote
paprika karotten eine zitrone nämlich
einen teelöffel salz und hier ein paar
gewürze und zwar jeweils ein thema so
kreuzkümmel kurkuma koriander samen und
paprika den halben teelöffel silly und
vier teelöffel sind vier esslöffel
tomatenmark 750 milliliter gemüsebrühe
habe ich die treppen auf der dose zwei
dosen und fleiß und eifer die kerzen
habe ich jetzt auf der dose genommen und
zwar aus dem grund wenn ihr frauke
mitglieder ernst nehmen müsse die am tag
vorher einreichen lassen über nacht und
können sie dann verwenden das können wir
natürlich auch machen wir nie die zeit
habt aber wenn ihr keine zeit habt
greift einfach auf die kirche eröffnet
wurde
ich nehm ich mal die ganze gemüse
kartoffeln und die kartoffeln zwiebel
knoblauch und ingwer werden jetzt
gestellt und der rest erst mal einfach
gewaschen
[Musik]
knoblauch ingwer und zwiebeln fein
gehackt und die restlichen gemüsesorten
werden dann in mundgerechte stücke
geschnitten
[Musik]
obwohl die kartoffel sind kartoffeln
reis ist bin ich wieder normalen
kartoffel verwandt und wir haben
natürlich einen entsetzlichen geschmack
das kommt durch den hohen zuckergehalt
aber dennoch ist die kartoffelsäcke sohn
fließt sehr kalorienarm und enthält ganz
viel vitamin d obwohl wie eben selbst
arm ist und hab ich ganz toll finde es
ganz viel betacarotin drin das ist die
vorstufe von vitamin a und das ist
selten und schmeckt und verkraftet
[Musik]
ich habe sie in einem großen topf
bereits olivenöl erhitzen die zwiebel
knoblauch 10 und den eng mit dazu und
berater das ganze etwa zwei minuten an
[Musik]
sind 54 beim sensations zweiter mann
raus und damit er auch in mundgerechte
stücke geschnitten die winkelsmühle
kennt ihr vielleicht aus der medizin
verwendet sie ja ganz gerne gegen
bauchschmerzen rendite deutlich zum
beispiel auf dem wettkampf müssen in der
muskulatur und tura bakterien ab
[Musik]
zudem schrieben gebe ich jetzt noch die
würfel dazu und wir werden etwa eine
million kann gebraten dadurch versteckt
richtig schönes aroma und jetzt kommt
aufs ganze gehen und dafür jetzt noch
ganz kurz mit angebracht die gebe ich
jetzt noch das einst mit dazu und will
das ganze gemüse mit der brühe auf und
das tomatenmark gibt es auch noch mit
rein gerne könnte es auch mit zum
anbraten dazu geben und hoffe ich jetzt
leider vergessen
kriegen sie ist so ein jetzt gebe ich
hier den deckel drauf und lass' gemüse
bei höchster hitze aufkochen stellt den
herd dann auch mittlere gibt es etwa für
20 minuten köcheln
wohl aber die kartoffeln und die
süßkartoffel noch bis haben
[Musik]
während hier noch fesselt kann ich schon
mal die beilage zubereiten bei uns
gibt's heute gucke ich kenne das aus
meiner kindheit meine mama hat und
regelmäßig zubereitet mit einem klick
joghurt ist es wichtig das perfekte
mittagessen
heute mache ich kurz hier im kleinen
topf und zwar besteht aus weizen gerste
oder hirse und im gegensatz zu wohl wird
nicht auf weißem muster hergestellt
sondern auch fries der krise einfach mal
hat es feuchter zu glücklichen geformt
und daraus entstanden
ich verwende jetzt gleich 300 dafür
brauche ich auch 300 milliliter wasser
das wasser gehe ich in einen topf und
lass es einfach mal kurz aufkochen
sobald das wasser kocht gebe ich noch
das haus mit rein und stellt in herten
auch schon wieder aus dem kreis coesfeld
nicht gekocht sondern nur dampf gegart
oder eben hier im wasser
wenn ich jetzt oben lassen wirklich
keinen kopf worauf also recht so umgibt
den deckel drauf und dann brauchst du
etwas zehn minuten bis die flüssigkeit
aufgedruckt aufgezogen wird und am ende
kommt noch der einkauf ist es soweit da
gebe ich jetzt friedlicher essen wie
dazu gebraucht unter nämlich nicht mehr
so lange im land wieder aufgewärmt
werden
den zitronenscheiben abschied mit rein
kleine und etwas zitronensäure mit rein
dann ruhig durchlasses nochmal etwas
zwei minuten warm werden und ich hatte
dies ebenso gemacht welcher in einem
kupfer topf kochen habe ich das ganze
aufkochen lassen und hat etwa fünf
minuten auf dem herd gekocht dann habe
ich den herrn aufgemacht und hat einfach
ziehen lassen und in der zeit vom 15
doch einem weit geworden einfach durch
die trolle wärmeleitung von kupfer
nur noch mit zeitungen zu verkürzen und
auf den kuckuck warten und dann kann man
gleich verlieren
den kuckuck locke ich jetzt mit zwei
gabeln auf und gibt dann nur noch das öl
mit rein
[Musik]
jetzt kann nichts verlieren der murat
freut wird auch schon aber auch war also
zuerst mal nämlich jetzt den kurs kurz
so ein kleines schiffchen 1
man kann wieder in form bringen
schön aufgrund macht die tollen farben
breite versteckte h motto vegetarisch
isst vegetarisch
aber du wirst keine fleisch- vermittlung
die [ __ ] in die torte oder und dann
endlich jp kelly und türkisch
orientalisch würdig auflagen machen
immer gleich viel rot und dann habe ich
hier noch petersilie und winter frisch
geharkt das kommt hier noch obendrauf
voila lieber horas torschütze für den
bahnhof geschleppt werden berichtet
murat braucht hier kein fleisch dafür
und liegt wo wir probleme das kartoffeln
und kartoffeln zucchini fenster nur
besonders robust kia erbsen das ist
wirklich aber normalerweise ich sage
jetzt mal lieber zwischen 200 deutsche
kultur und eigentlich wird man zudem
einfach keine beine mehr brauchen denn
man hat ja schon kartoffeln und ganzen
also in wirklichkeit aber die
orientalisch arabische türkische
mentalität besagt dass man dafür
trotzdem warum fladenbrot reicht ob
dabei lageberichts lieber vegetarisch
lecker und wenn man das ganze weg am
zubereiten möchten einfach den joghurt
weglassen weil alles andere ist wirklich
komplett frei von tierischen produkten
öl genutzt vom anbraten und ihm ist
wirklich nur den joghurt beim servieren
weglassen und falls ihr dieses rezept
nach machen wollten geht auf meine monat
auffällig ist dass sie es noch mal ganz
genau für euch wie gesagt die gewürze
sind wirklich super lecker und auf jeden
tag
und die lohnt sich auch sich dafür die
könnt ihr euch holen die bewusst sich
auch immer wieder in meinen rezepten und
dann müsst ihr euch ganz viel spaß
nachmachen und guten appetit und wird
jetzt auch umsetzen
bis zum nächsten mal die schläger weg
[Musik]
mehr
geklebt
[Musik]